FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Hi.
I am Francesc Campoy, and I'm
a developer programs engineer
for the Go team here at
Google in Mountain View.
And today I'm with Kurt.
KURT SCHWEHR: Hi.
I'm Kurt Schwehr.
I'm on the Google
Maps Ocean's team.
And I work on ocean data with
all sorts of different things.
But here today I'd like to
talk to you about ships.
And we like to look at all
the ships in the world.
There's a lot of them.
And what we have
is a visualization
here that shows you a
wide range of what's
out there, about all
these boats moving around.
They're pretty cool.
Lots of fun stuff going on.
But what this really is,
is a nice visualization
of the economic activity
of our entire world.
So this is really a global
scale problem to look at,
and what we've got are each
individual ship making up
just a small fraction
of this visualization.
The ship starts off with a
red at the newest point where
it is, and then over time it
fades out to a blue color,
and it gives you this nice,
streaky pattern that shows you
where the shipping lanes are,
where the people run around
in circles fishing, where people
are doing all of that business
that they do on ships.
It really is an
indicator of what's
going on in each
particular environment.
And what we're getting
here is the messages
are actually being broadcast
by the ships themselves.
And we're picking this up with
a satellite going over the top.
And a company called
SpaceQuest has been kind enough
to lend us the data to
do this example with,
and they're actually
collecting these ship positions
as they fly over, and they're
reporting them back to us.
And what we'd like to do
is, get millions of points
together and look at the
overall patterns and trends
to see what's happening
in our world here.
And it's a lot of
data, and if you just
work on a small laptop in
your own little environment,
it gets very challenging,
and your laptop
melts under the
load of all this,
and you don't get very far.
So now, we're looking at
this great visualization
here, Francesc,
that we've built.
How did we get here
to the point where
we have this amazing
ship traffic going on?
How do we build something
to get from that raw data
to this visualization?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
So that's actually a pretty
complex problem to solve,
and we ended up creating
this diagram here
where we can see all of
the different companies
that we ended up using.
So we have the ships sending
data through their GPS, the GPS
data, and then we
get that huge amount
of data, lots of points
for lots of ships.
And we want to extract
information off that.
We decided to use BigQuery
because you can actually
extract information really
easily, and iterate very fast,
and just have fun, and
find cool data about it
from huge amount of data.
But we had a little
problem-- that we
had to upload something
which is made of columns.
And actually the data
we get from the ships
is not at all made of columns or
at least doesn't look like it.
It's pretty cryptic.
So we had to decode it first.
So how did we do that?
You actually did it.
KURT SCHWEHR: Yeah.
So definitely, it's not
just encoded, it's armored.
So this data comes
out in a way that
is completely unreadable
to a normal human being.
But I had a C++ library that
I wrote over the last couple
years that actually just takes
that data and converts it
into a CSV column format
that's pretty manageable.
And then I wrote a
little Python wraparound
that to make it a little
bit easier to call.
That's great, but
you can't run that
on an App Engine, which is
where we're trying to get to.
So what we did instead was we
brought up a Compute Engine
instance with a little
Linux virtual machine.
And right there, we can run
the C++ code that I wrote,
and it then takes this
sort of cron job style,
takes data in from
cloud storage,
turns into a nice column
formatted text format,
and then loads it right
back into cloud storage
into a different bucket
where [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So it
ends up a CSV file pretty much
on--
KURT SCHWEHR: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
--cloud storage.
And then once we have that,
loading that data into BigQuery
it's really simple.
Just have to do a REST
code and just say, OK.
There's this new file.
I want you to load the data set.
And now we can actually start
having fun and iterating really
fast and finding cool data.
So we could find faulty
GPS signals or ships that
were fishing and all of
that really-- not really
simply, because this is actually
a pretty complicated problem--
but very fast.
You can actually just
write your query, run it,
and in a matter of seconds
you can get that response.
Then to show them the
map, what we had to do
is getting that
through App Engine app
and encode it somehow.
So we decided to
encode it in binary.
But that means that every
single time that there was query
coming from the browser
the App Engine app
could query BigQuery,
get that information,
and encode it and
send it to a browser.
KURT SCHWEHR: So that
was pretty fast, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Well, that's
around in the tens of
seconds every single time.
BigQuery is really
fast actually,
when you think about it.
Considering the huge amount
of data that we have,
tens of seconds is
actually pretty good.
But it's definitely not fast
enough for a web application,
definitely.
So that's why we added this
intermediary storage, which
is Datastore.
So regularly the App Engine
app could go to BigQuery,
up turn the latest data,
and store it in Datastore.
And now every time that
you get a query, instead
of going to BigQuery,
we could just
get the data from Datastore.
So that makes it faster.
KURT SCHWEHR: But
that's not fast enough?
I can see that.
Really?
You don't think
that's fast enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: No.
It's fast, but not fast enough.
It's going to take
less than 1 second,
but still around 1 second.
And it's taking long
because actually when
we get the data from
Datastore, we still
have to encode it
into binary format,
and actually that's
slightly complicated to do.
So what we decided to do
on top of the Datastore
is we get data from Datastore,
we encode it into binary,
and then we store
it in memcache.
And now every time that we
have a query, what happens--
KURT SCHWEHR: Is that fast?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
--is we get directly,
we get just a blob of
binary data from memcache,
and we send it back through
the HTTP connection.
KURT SCHWEHR: Now that's
fast enough, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Now, that's fast enough.
Yes.
KURT SCHWEHR: So
that's great, but why
did you have to go
with binary data
when most other web applications
you use just an ASCII JSON?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
So that's a good question.
We started JSON, actually.
And we realized that we had
this problem where we're
sending a lot of numbers,
latitude, longitude,
everything are
numbers pretty much.
And we're sending
them in JSON, which
means that we have the number.
We encode it in
JSON, therefore text.
And then it gets to the
browser, and the browser
has to decode it from
text back to a number.
And actually that decoding
encoding, it takes time.
It takes CPU time.
So what we did was just decide
to encode everything in binary
and use binary arrays
in JavaScript, which
means that now we can actually
get that binary code that we
get directly from the HTTP
response, put it into memory,
and just interpret it as
a binary array, an array
of floats in our case, and
just use that directly as data.
So you skip that encoding
and decoding part.
KURT SCHWEHR: And this
is why we have millions
of points in the
browser so quickly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
That's why you can actually
go through the application
and just pan around
or shift and decide,
I want to see the
data for this day,
and you won't have to
wait for 10 seconds.
This day will just appear
automatically instantly.
KURT SCHWEHR: Great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
What was the part
that you learned-- what
was the most interesting
for you out of this project?
KURT SCHWEHR: For me, this
was my first time working
in the cloud kind
of architecture,
and I was worried
that I would have
to wait for my team
members to work
on different parts
of the system.
And the neat thing is that I
just got to work on my pieces
and all these systems
let me decouple and work
in my particular favorite
language, which is Python.
I'm most comfortable there.
While you, for instance, were
in Go, and I didn't have to one,
worry about the fact
you were working in Go,
and I didn't have
to wait for you.
So for me that was
pretty exciting.
How did we pass data back and
forth that made that so easy?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
So since we had different
independent components,
so we had these data loggers
and the data transformation
and the App Engine
app, and all that.
We're completely independent
and communicating only
through Datastore and just
passing the data around
and using task queues.
And task queues to let the
other part of the application
know that there's
something to do about it.
And that is actually
one of the things
that I learned and I
discovered that it was really
powerful that using
task queues, it
allows you to have a
very robust system pretty
much without doing much.
Because you know that you're
going to try something,
and even if your
program is faulty
and you have some bugs,
things that happen sometimes,
you won't lose that data.
You will actually just fail
and send back a message saying,
oops.
Sorry.
And it will be ultimately
we'll try later on.
So you know that that
data will never be lost.
KURT SCHWEHR: So
task queue will pick
back up when your
code recovers from--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
You can, of course, change the
settings to add more backup
time or whatever.
But the default, actually we're
using the default settings,
and it works perfectly for us.
And then the second part,
for me, well I'm a gopher,
so of course, I use
Go for App Engine.
And I found out that using
Go on the App Engine part
was actually a big
win because most
of the time on the
cloud, what you're doing
is waiting for things to happen
or doing a lot of things all
of a sudden very, very fast.
So the fact that you can
actually do all of those things
very fast at the same
using concurrency,
it's something really important.
And doing it in Go is
actually really easy.
You just have to add some Go
routines and different channels
and four or five
lines of code, you
get something that
runs concurrently
and you get really
big win in efficiency.
KURT SCHWEHR: This
is what let us
scale when we start loading
huge blocks of stuff
in multiple [? browsers. ?]
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
Especially when you have to
load a lot of different things
from Datastore, the fact
that you can load all of them
at the same time and just wait
for the slowest one, that's
a big win rather than
doing sequentially.
And if you have 1,000, well, you
have to wait for 1,000 times n,
so, yeah.
KURT SCHWEHR: So this
is pretty exciting.
So now that we have
this new architecture,
what do we need
to do next to this
or where are we going
to be going with it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
So I think that the architecture
is pretty much ready
to be used.
And so the cool
thing now is that we
could consider using this
same architecture for very
different applications.
So the same way you are actually
showing here ships on a map,
you could also use it to
track whales in the ocean,
or you could use
it to track cars
on the highways, or anything
you can think about.
Or even not related to
Maps, you could actually
use the same
architecture as some way
to filter huge amounts
of data and extract
some information that is
something really small,
and it's like very
valuable information
out of a huge amount of data.
So yeah.
I think that the
next step is just
find out what's the
new cool application
to go with this architecture.
KURT SCHWEHR: Great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: So also, if you
are interested in knowing
more about this architecture
and how we built it,
and what we did with it,
we gave a talk in the
last edition of Google I/O
here in San Francisco, and
you can find the link here
in the description.
So look at it.
Have a look and enjoy it.
KURT SCHWEHR: And
just so you know,
we've released the decoding
library, LIB IAS for the ship
messages if you are interested
in playing with that,
and we hope to be
working through the rest
of open sourcing of
our little [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
We we'll definitely open
source on the App Engine app
code, and probably the data
logger, and all the rest.
So thanks for watching, and
keep an eye on Google Developers
Live channel for more
videos about our projects
using different Google products.